[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
well it was starting to feel inevitable
wasn't it and today it happened after
days of frenzied speculation Hugh
Edwards was named as a suspended BBC
presenter it was his wife Vicki Flint he
put the name into the public domain in a
statement issued on his behalf and
revealed that Hugh Edwards the highest
paid journalist at the BBC was also
receiving mental health care in hospital
well this is a statement in full
released by his wife in light of the
recent reporting regarding the BBC
presenter I'm making this statement on
behalf of my husband Hugh Edwards after
what had been five extremely difficult
days for our family I'm doing this
primarily out of concern for his mental
well-being and to protect our children
well Hugh is suffering from serious
mental health issues as is well
documented he has been treated for
severe depression in recent years for
the events the last few days have
greatly worsened matters he suffered
enough a serious episode and is
receiving inpatient hospital care where
he'll stay for this foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear he was first told
that there were allegations being made
against him last Thursday in the
circumstances and given Hugh's condition
I would like to ask that the privacy of
my family and everyone else caught up in
these upsetting events is respected she
continues I know that Hugh is deeply
sorry that so many colleagues have been
impacted by the recent media speculation
we hope this statement will bring that
to an end
well in the last hour the Sun newspaper
says it won't publish any further
allegations and we'll pass information
to the BBC for its investigation we can
go now to the BBC headquarters at some
Central London and talk to our
correspondent Ashner harinack um what's
the latest you can tell in sashna
well the very latest Sophie and this is
a very fast developing uh story is in
the last few minutes the director
general of the BBC Tim Davey has issued
an internal email to all members of
staff at the BBC essentially saying the
heart of this are friends and family and
colleagues of the person at the center
of these allegations Stu Edwards and now
they will continue their internal
investigations process and they will
take due care in doing so in light of
the fact that there are no criminal
proceedings at the heart of this from
either the Metropolitan police's point
of view nor South Wales police we also
have heard as you mentioned there Sophie
from the Sun newspaper a spokesperson
from the paper has said that they will
no longer publish any more allegations
about the presenter at the heart of this
they will also cooperate fully with that
internal investigation being conducted
by the BBC they also say at the Sun
newspaper that are going to hand over
redacted dossier of evidence as they
call it following their reporting of
this story of course it did start with
their article over the weekend in which
it was heavily anonymized they did not
name the presenter at the heart of this
but they simply said there had been
allegations featuring a high-profile
figure at the BBC a senior person at the
BBC involved in allegedly paying up to
000 pounds to a young person in exchange
for sexually explicit photos and it was
suggested that at the time these
payments started perhaps this person was
aged 17 years old
now of course it's been a frenzied few
days it has been very much a trial by
social media for so many of the BBC's
most high profile figures it has led to
a torrent of abuse for people like
Jeremy Vine for Gary lineker for people
like Nikki Campbell one of the
broadcasters as part of the corporation
and they have come out and said it's
very much not us and tonight in the last
few hours we heard and received a
statement from the wife of the BBC
presenter Hugh Edwards Vicki flind who
in a statement reflected on the fact
that well she not only named the
presenter at the heart of these
allegations and referenced the fact that
it was Q up until this point he remained
an unidentified presenter but also made
reference to the fact that there are
very serious mental health issues that
this presenter is currently contending
with and we have known in the past that
Hugh Edwards is someone who has spoken
very openly very bravely as we said
about his bouts with depression recently
did a Welsh language documentary talking
about it and so it appears that he finds
himself within hospital as per this
statement in the words of his wife she
says that he is suffering another
episode and he is being treated as an
inpatient within Hospital receiving care
following this frenzy over the last few
days so fast developing movements a
statement from the Sun that they will
cooperate with a BBC's investigation
thank you very much indeed Ashna they're
reporting from outside the BBC
well I just want to bring you the
statement from the Met police issued
earlier because as Ashley was saying
they aren't taking any further action
the force said detectors from the Met
specialist crime command have now
concluded their assessment and have
determined there's no information to
indicate that a criminal offense has
been committed
in reaching this decision they've spoken
to a number of parties including the BBC
and the alleged complainants and the
alleged complainants family both via
another police force there's no further
police action as such the Met has
advised the BBC it can continue with its
internal investigation we are aware of
media reporting of further allegations
against the same individual no specific
details or information about these
allegations have been passed to us and
therefore there is no police action at
this time should evidence of criminality
or safeguarding issues be identified at
any point we would expect matters to be
referred to the relevant police force
from the Met police so you're up to date
on the story unfolding so far and we are
now joined by someone who knows Hugh
Edwards pretty well someone who knows
this place pretty well as well the
former editor at large of Sky News Alan
Bolton who now regularly appears on
times radio on talk TV as well good to
you happy with us Adam
what is your take on this well as first
thing to say is it's a very sad State of
Affairs that obviously one feels for uh
Hugh in in hospital and one also feels
for his wife and family and I know Vicki
as well you know appeared on program
she's produced both of them excellent
journalists you know whose work I I
admire
my take though is there's going to be a
lot of recriminations now they're going
to be people saying well the sun should
never have done the story uh and uh I
would take the count of you I would say
that
people such as yourself such as
ourselves on television who hold others
to account for their behavior have to be
prepared to be held account for Behavior
not just on the yardstick of criminality
I mean there are a lot of people whose
careers have been ended a long way short
of criminality because it was felt that
they were bringing the organization
which they represented into into
distribute so you don't think the
yardsticks should be what was illegal
then because that is what some people
are saying right they're saying that
actually look nothing illegal has
necessarily been done here the police
say that there's nothing to talk about I
mean I'm not saying these allegations
are true but
on the face of what the sun said and the
sun didn't actually ever alleged
criminality it says that
a man approaching 60
paid large amounts of money to a young
person under 20.
for some sort of exchange of illicit
material and that subsequently he phoned
that young person up and threatened them
now I think most people would regard
that as fairly representable behavior
I'm not saying that's true themselves
says that nothing inappropriate happens
well as reported by the sun this young
person is clearly a very vulnerable
person
um who is according to the son someone
who has a very serious drug problem
so I would have thought that what they
say themselves is probably less reliable
than what their parents have said in
this case and then we do have
the interesting extra piece of
information which the BBC put out
yesterday again not alleging criminality
but alleging that the same presenter
had made threatening phone calls to
another young person so all I'm saying
is I think this is behavior which
you know
if I'd done it or you'd done it I think
we would be held to account by our
employers do you think that presenters
then people in the public eye if you
like that you know TV presenters in
particular should be held to a different
standard than from the general public
yes I you know there is this whole
question of the right to privacy but I
think people who are in the public eye
and by definition if you're presenting a
news program every night you're in the
public eye if you are subject to
personal profiles right talking about
your life and and your experience
because that's good publicity for you I
do think you expose yourself more to
examination than than someone who's
leading are quite low software although
as you know you work for the news of the
world once I mean you know people we've
never heard of who do uh you know
shocking things they can find themselves
in the newspapers as well yeah although
I think I feel like the the Privacy
standards have changed have changed
quite fundamentally that I think is one
thing again which we should look at I
mean people are saying oh you know
privacy standards aren't tight enough I
would actually take the other view I
would say that
the whole business of the Sun not being
able to name this person and still us
not really knowing the full details of
what went on
has resulted in a kind of legal standoff
over five days which has damaged
everybody including you and you know had
the story been published he could have
come out and said
not true and effect is all over and the
consequences for the sun probably would
have been certainly that it would have
been sued and had to pay out a lot of
money and possibly has happened to the
news of the world over phone hacking it
might have gone out of business what um
what do the BBC as well these are all
here do you think that the BBC has
questions to answer and I guess that in
their defense they would say that they
did try to contact you know the parents
of the I mean I think they've been
caught out I think it's possibly
understandable but you know with
hindsight
fairly serious complaint was made and it
does surprise me where I over that
period since May the 19th it's not
really clear that they spoke to Hugh at
all about it and now they get lots of
complaints about a lot of people but I I
think Tim Dave would probably accept
that you know they should have done that
that said I think
once the sun went to it with allegations
I I think the BBC's handling of this has
been exemplary I mean their news
Operation has reported it as you know
just as uh firmly as Sky News uh and
um they have been prepared to
hold themselves to account for for the
way they've behaved so I I
you know that one interesting thing
yesterday one of the things which sort
of tipped this case was the decision of
the BBC to tell us about the second
young person
who allegedly was or they say they had
evidence that he had been phoned by uh
with the person we now know is you and
there was some kind of coercion in in
those exchanges we don't know the
exchanges and also yeah but they told us
they told like they were effectively
threatening to expose it yeah but the
BBC told us that it was about the same
person which they didn't have to do
and and that seemed to me that you know
that showed
a certain amount of impatience within
the corporation what would you say to
some people who think look this is a
gross invasion of privacy this is a guy
who is now in hospital with mental
health issues his family's life have
been ruined the sun is an organization
that is always going for the BBC and of
course you Adam Bolton are going to
defend the sun because you are also
doing work for talk TV and for times
radio
well I wouldn't work for them if I
thought
you know what what people were doing are
wrong I think people do make mistakes I
you know I wouldn't defend a lot of the
things which have happened at uh Fox
News for example but I take the view and
I'm someone who've had my own
private life you know double page
spreads in in tablet newspapers someone
saying that if you do take action you
have to be prepared for the consequences
of of daylight being cast on it people
can make their own judgments whether
they think it's particularly comfortable
or not what would be wrong
is if this is all made up and fabricated
and it's not true but so far we have not
had
any denial specific denial of the
allegations raised against the person we
now know is Hugh Edwards by anybody by
his wife or anybody else they certainly
said they're going to respond so at the
moment it looks like it's as indeed the
director general of the BBC said
legitimate public interest uh it's very
much Adam always get to talk thank you
for coming on the show
Adam oh there we go Adam uh Bolton there
speaking to us we can get a bit of
reaction from the government now a
little earlier I spoke to the security
minister TOM tiger hat and I will be
asking him about the NATO Summit of
course and the war in Ukraine but we did
start with the breaking news about Hugh
Edwards
the suspended BBC presenters been named
in a statement issued by his wife as few
Edwards what's your reaction to this
first of all I'm very surprised at all
that has happened and secondly I'd like
to say these are very serious
allegations that really should be
investigated properly mostly for the
alleged victims but also for everybody
involved all those affected by it so I'm
afraid I'm not going to say very much
more about it because the police have
been asked to assess the situation
correctly and they'll be making a
decision as to what further actions to
take or so my understanding is the
police have said that they won't be
pressing charges that there is no
evidence of criminality
in that case it's a time to draw a line
under your view well look there are
various different issues to look at I'm
sure here and the BBC will have to make
a decision about that I'm afraid I don't
know the details of the case I know that
uh Lucy Fraser the cultural secretary is
keeping very closely informed and
speaking to Tim Davey the head of the
BBC about these issues and they'll have
to make a decision as to what's going on
but I I do understand that these are
serious allegations uh that apply in
various different ways and so I think
the BBC have a will have a
responsibility to report back when
they've made their inquiries
there's been lots of speculation while
the peasant's name was kept a secret
Jeremy Vine for example among just one
person speaking out to say that he
thought that the individual should be
named do you think that's the right
thing now that this name's in the public
domain well I think one of the things
we've always got to be careful of is
trial by social media
and that's not just because of course
people are innocent until they're proven
guilty but it's also because
in some circumstances if the allegations
were to lead to a criminal trial you
don't want that trial to be prejudiced
by things that people may have said in
public or the way in which a jury may
have been influenced and so it is
important that we respect the rule of
law that we respect the principles that
we've set out over many hundreds of
years to protect every citizen so that
we can get Fair trials and those who are
guilty can be properly tried and
properly sentenced do you think the
social media companies are doing enough
I mean when Sky News for example
approached them for comment asked for an
interview we were sent a poo emoji
I think that is a remarkable thing to
have sent and certainly not appropriate
I mean
look there are some social media
companies that have behaved extremely
well over many years and others frankly
have questions to answer so I hope very
much that those who are struggling with
understanding their social
responsibilities will be thinking hard
about how they respond
um I just want to talk a little bit
about the statement that's been issued
um it's literally just come out just
before
um I've been speaking to you so I
understand you may not have had much
time to digest it
uh but the wife of Hugh Edwards says
that he is now receiving inpatient
hospital care for serious mental health
issues and he'll stay there for the
foreseeable future
um
how I guess do you feel sorry for him
the number of people who are affected by
serious mental health issues in this
country is much greater than I think
many realize and it's something that I'm
very pleased that the government and in
fact the Prince of Wales have been
championing over recent years and I
think it's important that we take it
seriously but I also think it's
important that victims have access to
Justice at different kinds now I
understand the police have said they're
not they don't see a reason to continue
with these investigations
but we've got to keep a balance there
and in this circumstance I think we've
got to give the family a bit of space
and I think the right thing to do is to
allow the BBC to conduct whatever
investigation they feel they need to do
and to make sure that the family are not
dragged into this after all
you know there's one person who's been
alleged to have done wrong not his whole
family
um do you think the BBC have got
questions to answer about how they've
handled it
I think when this is over a lot of
people will be looking over what
happened and when when decisions were
taken and how they were taken the
trouble with these
questions and I appreciate why you're
asking them but the difficulty I have in
answering them is I have very partial
information
and I don't want to rush to judgment
when actually these are serious
allegations
and the correct thing to do is to find
out what actually happened before
casting aspersions on anyone do you
think um I'm sure I can probably predict
the answer to this but do you think
we'll be seeing Hugh Edwards on the news
at 10 again or should we I mean that's a
that's very difficult for me to answer I
mean I can't I can't second guess this
at all but it's the these these are very
very uh important questions for the BBC
to answer now it's got to conduct its
own internal investigation I'm sure they
will I'm sure they'll keep the culture
secretary and uh informed and I'm sure
at the end of it they'll let us know
what the investigation found that these
you know we've got to give space for
those investigations to happen for
fairness not just uh for Mr Edwards but
for those individuals who are brought
into it as well okay
um well thank you for talking about the
story it's a it's a difficult story for
you know to to talk about when you as
you say this we've only just got the
name just now before you came into the
studios we do appreciate that
um I'm Keen to talk to you a little bit
about NATO as well and the uh the big
Summit that happened today and it feels
like it was
Throne of course should we say by some
statements that we got from the defense
secretary and Wallace saying that
ukrainians need to show gratitude
towards countries providing with weapons
we're not Amazon
well I think one of the things that
we've got to look at is
the way in which the United Kingdom has
supported Ukraine so incredibly strongly
not actually just the last 18 months but
really since 2014-15 when we started
training the Ukrainian armed forces and
and became very active in supporting
Ukraine and making sure in fact that
they were prepared for what then
happened not that we could have
predicted it but but what then happened
and you know what the Prime Minister has
done what Rishi has done over the last
few months is really extremely important
he's been absolutely front and center of
not only making sure the ukrainians have
the weapons they need but also as you
would have heard in making it quite
clear that NATO you know that Ukraine's
places in NATO and I think those
statements are extremely important I
wasn't asking about what Russia CNET has
done for Ukraine I'm asking you about
what Ben Wallace has said today that
implying ukrainians aren't being
grateful enough I think to be fair when
you read the whole of the time story and
and I know you have it it he's making
the point that when negotiating with
American legislators some of whom don't
view the Ukraine conflict in the same
way that we do which is that the
ukrainians are quite literally on the
front line of freedom I don't buy that
I'll be honest because if I'll just will
read you a direct quote I said to the
ukrainians last year he Ben Wallace when
I drove 11 hours to them to be given a
list I said I am not Amazon sounds like
he's talking about his own view as well
he may be but the paragraph before that
speaks about associating with American
normal he admits that he told the
ukrainians directly I am not Amazon well
I think I think it's important that we
make sure that we are alongside Ukraine
he also said in this in that bit when he
was that he drove 11 hours to Kiev I
mean it sounds a little bit like you
know he's saying why should I be giving
up my time I had to drive 11 hours
someone in the context of the Ukraine
war having to drive 11 hours isn't
exactly really putting yourself out that
much I don't think that's quite Fair on
Ben Ben was the minister responsible
when we got the end laws into Kiev in
February and if you'll remember at the
time there was a lot of people in other
countries especially but there was a lot
of people who were saying we shouldn't
be sending weapons at that moment
because Kia was going to fall anyway and
the Russians were going to roll over the
border and it was all over and Ben was
absolutely instrumental at making sure
that they had the weapons that were
essential for those first few days that
was the end laws and then maintained
that support throughout so Ben's in a
different position to many in Ukraine
Ben can be pretty Frank with the
ukrainians because he's been there since
the beginning he's been absolutely side
by side with the Ukrainian Armed Forces
making sure they had the capability so I
think you know when looking at these
comments you've got to look at them in
context Ben has been absolutely key to
this operation from the UK perspective
of course but also from the Ukrainian
perspective and the the UK is in a very
particular place it's one of the things
that's very encouraging when I was in
Ukraine in August and indeed a few
months before that one of the things
that really struck me was how
pro-british how very grateful ukrainians
are and have been to the UK it's been
something that's really touched me but
you know I I'm also very grateful to the
ukrainians they are genuinely defending
European Freedom uh in the struggle that
they're conducting at the moment against
Russian aggression it is a
then
that people are getting Ukraine fatigue
now I don't think there is I mean look I
I travel around the United Kingdom a lot
and one but elsewhere as well in the US
for example you know we can see what's
playing out with the upcoming
presidential election is there a worry
that actually some politicians sometimes
the public indeed might be looking at
the amount of money there are weapons
going there and thinking how long is
this going to go on for so I think it's
reasonable for politicians
representatives of their communities to
ask how much money is being spent and is
it being spent appropriately I think
that's a perfectly reasonable thing for
for people to ask what's quite striking
is all the way across the United Kingdom
you see Ukrainian Flags everywhere I
mean you see them on public buildings
more private buildings you see them in
shops you see them on supermarkets you
see them all over the place you know the
level of support for Ukraine and the
Ukrainian people here is enormous and
when you look at when we open the doors
to ukrainians to come and seek shelter
in the UK the number of people I mean
I'm I'm always deeply touched by the
generosity of the British public and how
many people open their homes quite
literally open their homes to ukrainians
who needed somewhere to shelter as this
war against them was being conducted by
this evil Russian regime couple of other
questions while I've got you um you've
been looking at the threats the UK in
particular on the sort of cyber security
side How concerned are you about China
in particular in this space well look
we've seen I'm afraid to say a hostile
activity by States against the UK
growing in recent years we've seen it
getting worse and we've seen cyber
attacks as you mentioned we've seen from
Iran we've seen attempted assassinations
as Ken McCullum the head of MI5 reported
only a few months ago we've seen
disinformation we've seen a whole series
of different ways in which hostile
states are trying to
dude harm to the United Kingdom and harm
the British people in our freedoms and
that's why you know this government has
reacted so clearly because the first
duty of any government is to protect the
British people and that's exactly what
we've done so we've introduced as you
know the National Security Act which is
a fantastically important piece of
legislation it does fundamentally it
does two things the first is it's it
makes sure that we're a harder targeted
it deters aggression and it disrupts
aggressors in their actions and the
second thing it does is it gives powers
to our intelligence services to pursue
those who either are trying to do harm
to us or are siding with those who try
to do harm with us and I think that's
incredibly important a very important
response to some of the aggressions that
we've heard about and then just finally
um I want to ask you about pay in this
public sector and because of course
we're getting the recommendations
through from the pay bodies it's a time
of high inflation the government is wary
about giving too many payrolls as out
I just want to talk to you about the
armed forces in particular there have
been reports that the pay review bodies
have recommended pay increases six to
six point five percent
um do you think that's about right do
you think they deserve a pay rise of
that level look I'm I'm not going to
conduct a negotiation
um the Ben's actually conducting at this
moment because I'm not uh in in the
details of it but I think what's really
important to recognize is that when pay
review bodies make recommendations we
take them extremely seriously but we've
got to also take something else very
seriously and that's inflation you know
we all know that inflation is a thief in
the night it it steals off literally
everybody it erodes your savings it
erodes your earnings it's an incredibly
damaging economic problem and that's why
getting inflation down is so incredibly
important and using every lever that we
can to make sure that we're controlling
inflation in this country even if it's
the people who are
country putting their lives on the line
not on massive salaries well I was a
soldier as you know for 13 years and
um I I think it's an incredibly
important job to do and I'm incredibly
grateful for those who are doing it
today and I think we should recognize
the service that people give in the
armed forces they be prioritized do you
think when it comes to payroll well I'm
very glad to say the Armed Forces
regularly are prioritized and this
government has prioritized the Armed
Forces many different well this
Forces many different ways I don't know
if you remember when Rishi was
Chancellor uh he gave a huge boost to
the defense budget negotiated by Ben but
you know delivered by Rishi and Rishi
has been absolutely front and center in
making sure that armed forces are
properly equipped and ready to serve
thank you very much thank you
responding to the news about Hugh
Edwards but also of course discussing
NATO and Ukraine plus pay for the Armed
Forces as well
you're watching the take live in
Westminster up next we will bring you
the latest on the Hugh Edwards BBC
crisis we'll also be taking a closer
look at relations between NATO and
Ukraine after today's Summit
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well let's get
more now on our top story because Hugh
Edwards has been named as the BBC
presenter facing allegations about his
behavior sparking a crisis at the
corporation but we can speak now to
answer Campbell the former Darling
Street communications director and
mental health campaigner you knew who
you didn't knew you worked with him on
Mental Health
campaigns in particular what do you make
of the statement that's been released by
his wife
well no I I know him rather than I knew
him uh you know we shouldn't be sort of
talking the past tense about somebody
who's a very very fine broadcaster and
there's clearly a current state and you
know in a state of some distress look I
found the statement by his wife very
very sad
um I think he is as I say a terrific
broadcaster he's somebody who's been
very very open about his mental health
struggles I think this is as much a
story about the way that our media
operates as it is about him I think this
is in part about the Murdoch press with
a constant sort of attempts to undermine
and denigrate the BBC I'm not saying
he's not newsworthy uh if he's done
something wrong or inappropriate but
it's interesting to see how they wound
back from some of the really serious
allegations that they made the police
have now said they don't see that
there's a a crime to be investigated at
all and tonight the sun's saying that
they don't intend to make any fresh
allegations that says to me that they
feel they're on pretty dodgy ground so
what we've been left with is almost a
week now in which it seems to me the
British media has lost any sense of
perspective it's LED virtually every
bulletin in every media outlet for the
last few days when there's so much else
going on in the country in the world
that frankly I think is of Greater
interest to people and Frank and also of
Greater significance
well what specifically has the sun wrote
back on
well they they I noticed they introduced
the word allegedly yesterday uh look
they've they've they've they've accused
an unnamed BBC presenter of committing a
series of crimes
um have they done that sorry just
because have they accused him of
committing a crime
Mr they wrote and read the story the way
they've covered up until this point
where they now seem to be saying they're
going to row back they're not going to
be making any further allegations and my
point is that I just think it's
incredible the extent to which the
broadcast media allows itself to become
a kind of mouthpiece for some of these
newspapers that are players in the
political scene not just Spectators I
mean seriously Sophie is this the most
important thing that's been happening in
the world for the last five days
is it not a more serious Scandal that
for example a former prime minister of
ours who said he was going to hand over
all his coven messages has not done so
is that not really more serious than
this here's what's happening in Ukraine
not more serious than this I'm not
saying it's not newsworthy I'm not
saying that newspapers don't have the
right and indeed the duty to investigate
wrongdoing as they see it if it's
brought to their attention look please
let's stop pretending that this is the
most important thing happening in the
country right now
no I don't think that to be frank you
and I are in any different slides of the
argument in saying that Ukraine is more
important than this story I think we are
absolutely on the same page when it
comes to that do you have any concerns
about how the BBC has handled this
well I think at the start I thought they
handled it well because I mean I've had
a lot of experience with disputes with
the BBC and I think sometimes the BBC
has tended to almost use its own news
agenda and its news outlets to project
its own line of something in its own
portrayal of an issue I think on this
they've actually gone too far the other
way I think that when the story broke
they rightly covered it they rightly
said that they would be they were
investigating it but since then I think
they've played into the frenzy
um you know it's almost like they've
been waiting to see what the sun says
next so they can lead the news on it
again and then the I think there's sort
of rather unpleasant uh kind of you know
game of trying to push their name out
there
um so I I think that look is that
they're in a very difficult position but
I do think they need to stand up for
themselves a bit better than they do and
I don't think it's unfair or
unreasonable for people at the BBC to
say that this story is part of this
wider agenda of the right wing price to
try to undermine the BBC I think they
should be saying that pretty clear
really
how much sympathy do you have for human
self
oh massive amount and also for his for
his family and frankly for the you know
for the other family that that's been
involved in this where clearly there are
things going on there that none of us
know about this is what's been so crazy
about this story is none of us actually
know any of the facts all we've got to
go on is what somebody has said to the
Sun newspaper which has been then denied
by a lawyer of the person about whom
it's being said and meanwhile we
discover that the guy that's the kind of
public figure at the heart of this is in
hospital so I feel incredible sympathy
for him and for his family and I really
do hope that once we're through this
kind of latest chapter in the frenzy of
the name finally being out there in the
public domain I really do hope that his
wife Vicki Flynn the statement that she
made today and when she says you know
can they please be allowed a bit of
privacy I just hope that people can can
respect that because look I've had um
I've had bouts of depression when in the
public eye and when I've been at the
center of frenzies and I can tell you
that the depression doesn't help
um and but also nor does the attention
and look if people have done wrong if
people have done things that are go
against the values and the principles of
the organizations for which they work
then that has to be called out has to be
investigated but what we've seen here is
a story where we thought we were dealing
with some kind of you know Jimmy Savile
type situation and the police get called
in and the police find this diet very
very quickly do you know what there's
not much to see in here and now we're
left with this kind of you know frankly
emotional rather tragic situation but I
just think that Hugh Edwards is I think
he's very liked in the country I think
he's much respected as a journalist and
I think that that people should take at
face value what his wife has said
tonight and respect what she's saying
about allowing them to sort this out for
themselves and the BBC frankly should
carry on with their internal
investigation put this story where it
should be which is very low down the
news agenda and you know focus on bigger
and more important issues in the in the
the role as public service broadcaster
okay thank you very much indeed always
good to talk ask Campbell there yeah so
if you're the best bye-bye
well let's move on now and get some
ration from labor shall we because on
the show today we also spoke to the show
defense secretary John Healy I did move
on to the NATO Summit but I started by
asking about the naming a few Edwards
she's taken the decision to do that
um
these are serious allegations and
they've quite clearly taken a terrible
toll on the alleged victims and their
families and also on Hugh Edwards and
his family I hope the temperature can be
taken out of this now and that the level
of speculation and attention can be
reduced and allow the BBC to do what
they need to do now which is fully
investigate the allegations and do that
without any more delay that's
interesting do you think that they're
part of the issue was that BBC were slow
of the Mark if you like well up until
today it was in the hands of the police
so the BBC had to stay their
investigation
um
now they need to pick this up they need
to get to the bottom of the allegations
and
in the meantime I think we can all have
a great deal of concern for those
victims alleged victims and their
families and also
for Hugh Edwards and his family too what
do you think is serious about the
allegations
I think the
do you know I really don't want to get
into that in the sense that it it's a
complicated story they've been
conflicting reports
um and this now needs to be bottomed out
so the rest of us are I think best
served
um by allowing the BBC to do that and
waiting for the
full facts actually to be established
the question marks about how the BBC's
handled this obviously the initial
allegation from from the mother
um she said that she did go to the BBC
but nothing happened
well the reports have
been conflicting haven't they
um as well as confusing to those not
involved and part of a very complicated
story so I'm sure the BBC will first and
foremost want to sort out the
investigation in these allegations but
we'll want to look at its processes to
make sure that it's able to do these
promptly and professionally in the
future
um just looking at the statement that
we've had
um about Hugh Edwards from his wife she
says that she was suffering from serious
mental health issues the events the last
few days have greatly worse and matters
he suffered another serious episode and
he's now receiving inpatient hospital
care where he'll stay for the
foreseeable future
do you feel sorry for him
I think we've got to all do now what
she's also asked for which is privacy
and respect
um so that these matters can be properly
settled and that's the BBC's job okay
now let's talk about NATO has it been a
successful meeting do you think
it's been a very successful Summit uh in
my view the first Focus has probably
been on Ukraine
and there are
uh
there's been a big boost to the military
help available to Ukraine now but also
some important longer term security
agreements in place and the bilateral
agreements that through the G7 Britain
is going to be a part of have our full
labor support I think equally
significant
has been the
reboot of Defense planning that NATO has
undertaken in order to deal with Russian
aggression we may face over the next
decade and above all the unity of the
NATO Nations so the natives come out
stronger
it's come out more unified and it's come
out bigger of course with the accession
of Sweden as well as Finland as new
members and those things are the very
last things that President Putin would
have wanted to see
they're always quite carefully
choreographed and we've had something
that has
blown some of that choreography out and
I'm talking about the comments by Ben
Wallace the defense secretary who said
that ukrainians need to show gratitude
towards countries providing them with
weapons he says I said to the ukrainians
last year when I drove 11 hours to be
given a list of weapons that they
wouldn't I said I am not Amazon
would make that
for me the most important thing is the
ukrainians are fighting for the freedom
and future of their country
and president zielinski wants more
military help yesterday of course he
does
and I think the last thing he needs is
public lectures about gratitude
particularly as they also overshadow a
successful NATO Summit which has left
NATO stronger and has given Ukraine
greater security not just immediate
military help but some of the
reassurances and agreements they'll need
it's very measured how you talk about
all these things but at the same time
like you know we're kind of if you
and
president zielinski a guy who has his
country has been invaded by Russia he's
seen playgrounds being grown up blown up
we've all seen the pictures of apartment
blocks demolished he's been told he
should be more grateful
extraordinary things so important to be
measured
um he's a war leader displaying great
courage as the ukrainians have in their
fights civilians and Military alike what
he's also said and this for me is the
most important thing he said at the end
of the summer it is that this is a
significant security victory for Ukraine
for our people and for our children okay
um just finally I just want to talk to
you about public sector pay because the
peer review bodies are making
recommendations the Armed Forces of
course are tied up in this and we
understand that the pay rise is around
six to six point five percent for them
would labor Grant it
well the average value of all workers
pay has fallen overcome your show
defenseman Stern you know what would you
do would you grant it
we haven't seen the pay review bodies
that the governments have for some time
um that's a decision for the government
now and a responsibility for the
government now would you
belongs you say you're the government
this is the Army going to be listening
to this kind of answer sure would you be
in the year of the chancellor saying
these guys need to be top of your list
they need they need six percent you need
to accept the pay review bodies I'm just
trying to get a sense of you know if you
want to be defense secretary after the
election what kind of Defense secretary
are you going to be
I'll be a defense secretary that
restores the moral contract this nation
makes with those who serve and their
families but at this stage we haven't
seen this year's pay review body
we don't know how the government's going
to respond they've still got the Autumn
statement and the spring statement next
year we don't know what inflation is
going to be like we don't know what the
state of the economy is going to be like
what we do know and if you have a labor
government they would be taking the pay
review body review reports seriously
they would be bringing round the table
those who need to sort out the
settlements for the future and it isn't
just about pay it isn't just about
paying the forces just like it isn't for
the NHS or for teachers they're worried
about recruitment retention Workforce
load and high level of vacancies thank
you very much bigger problems the
responsibility of the minister thank you
very much
Shadow defense secretary there John
Healy after that NATO Summit well we can
speak now I'm pleased to say to the
German ambassador Miguel bergo thank you
very much for being with us on the
program this evening was it a successful
Summit then I would say that I agree
with John Healy it was a successful
Summit we have Finland for the first
time participating as full member we had
the agreement on Sweden so turkey is
going to ratify
Sweden's membership we have a very
strong security pledge for Ukraine we
have a path a kind of road map towards
future membership of Ukraine so I think
it was a very successful Summit do we
really have a road map to membership for
Ukraine we haven't got any specific
conditions which is what they want yeah
but but I think the key issue is that we
all want to see that the war ends first
because no country will become member of
NATO during a war so the war has to end
and then there are some conditions which
will be put forward to any new member so
on interoperability on Democratic
control of the army so these are very
basic conditions but it was very clear
if you look at the text that there is a
very strong commitment to admit Ukraine
into NATO once these conditions are met
we can obviously understand why Ukraine
want to join NATO and also why there is
a caution to do it now because obviously
under Article 5 if someone invades a
NATO member State then the others have
to come in to defend it yes
um is it right to say that I say I guess
the US and Germany are on the more
cautious side of the argument here
I would not say that this is only
Germany and the US I think there was a
wider understanding and nobody
had a different view on the question
that the war has to end first
so we all want to see that this war
comes to an end hopefully with the
victory of Ukraine and then I think the
basis and the groundwork can be laid for
foreign
we are doing that if you look at
training if you look at all the support
package so Germany has just pledged
another 700 million new leopard tanks
new Patriot systems so we are doing a
lot and I think it's very important to
underline that these security pledges by
the G7 will cover this time between the
NATO Summit and the moment of a possible
membership of Ukraine so we have very
strong security pledges which will give
I think Ukraine the necessary guarantees
for this time
um I want to ask your opinion on some
comments that were made by Ben Wallace
the defense secretary in the UK who said
Ukraine should show more gratitude for
some of the weapons from other countries
he said that he'd actually told Ukraine
we're not Amazon what'd you make of that
yeah I think Ukraine has shown gratitude
and we see this every day on the front
line the reactions from Ukrainian
soldiers I think we would not be in the
situation we are now without this this
support from the West
I imagine that what Ben Wallace wanted
to say is that we all and I think it's
something UK is facing the same way as
Germany we don't have enough ammunition
in our stocks to continue to deliver
without new industrial production and
that has been part of the discussions in
NATO and we have now very clear
commitments on strengthening industrial
production so that we are able to
deliver the necessary weapons and
ammunition and I think also that we and
that's because basically yes other
countries in NATO might be running out
or that yeah also our stocks are limited
and I think that's what he wanted to say
our stocks are limited and we need to
make sure that the Russians also see
that we produce more ammunition and send
more weapons than Russia can produce
because only if Putin understands that
he cannot win this war by waiting or
playing on time then things might start
to change just finally
um talking about other Global issues
we're expecting to hear a bit of a
strategy on China from Germany in the
coming days has there been a shift in
the German position on China do you
think
yes it has and I would say the lesson we
have learned from Russia's war of
aggression is that we need to be more
resilient we have to reduce
overdependencies if you look at
semiconductors if you look at rare
Earths for energy transition 90 percent
come from China so we will not be
successful if we don't reduce our over
dependency and regrettably we have seen
a China policy which is becoming uh more
and more assertive aggressive and we
have to react to that but let me say
this China strategy will be published
but I'm pretty sure that we are more or
less on the same line as the British
government on China uh interesting
really great to talk to you always and
good to have you on the show thank you
very much thank you
uh right we talked a lot about
um International Politics on the program
but we can go to domestic at politics uh
to Sam just put his phone away or nearly
caught him scrolling there but he's just
about got away with it right let's have
a look at some of those upcoming
by-elections uh shall we because we have
a a trio of them coming up haven't we
what's going on that's right so if you
start with a quiz question when was the
last time a prime minister sitting prime
minister lost three by-elections the
same day no idea I thought you'd say
that July 1968 Harold Wilson was the
last prime minister to see such scale of
defeat yet that is what Tori ampere's
fear next week uh one of them is where
Boris Johnson uh was the representative
until he resigned a few weeks ago you
can see the conservatives uh well in the
lead uh the conservatives expected to
lose this one there is a row over the
congestion charge the Euless which is
the tourist thing is the only chance of
hanging on to it but they're really not
sure let's look at the next one uh which
is uh uh Selby and Einstein this is in
many ways the most interesting this
would require a record of what breaking
18 swing for the labor party to overtake
the Tories and win this seat that would
be the biggest swing in this Parliament
it would require overturning uh some
by-election records now some Tories
think they may yet win this uh and the
last uh potential loss which could
actually go to the little Democrats
that's the seat vacated uh by David
Warburton down in the southwest and if
we could look at that slide
maybe not ah there we go Somerton and
fro look at that one and again this used
to be liberal Democrat until it was
swept away at the end of the Coalition
years in 2015 uh and the Tories took it
uh but now I think which was a little
Democrats pretty confident that they'll
be able to overturn uh at least uh some
of that it's going to be a difficult end
of end of term I think much does it
matter we know that these could be
difficult results but is it going to
make any material difference you think
if they do lose them I think
a lot of MPS are looking at Selby uh at
amsty because if there's a
record-breaking loss that suggests that
the Tories could be on calls for a Total
Wipeout in the general election and is
there any chance of Richard scenic
facing a leadership challenge or
anything like that or is this actually
just more grumblings more problems from
the sidelines I think at this point
there is no realistic chance of a change
the question is whether or not the sort
of motivation and the uh optimism inside
the conservative party which is not in
great Supply I have to be honest when
you talk to Tori MPS uh whether that
drones away yet further uh how strong is
the campaigning operation uh how
committed are MPS to uh to trying to go
that extra mile all of those things I
think are in play at the moment and
people are looking at these results next
week yeah they certainly will you will
be looking at those results uh next week
I have no doubt that Sam is going to be
right there on the front line at
covering the by-elections and what they
all mean I'll also be uh here on Friday
chewing over at all the results and what
they mean on Sky News thanks very much
Sam
that's it for the take this week we'll
be back uh next up it is Sky News at 10
thank you very much for watching
foreign